[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
chef mais moi notre kebab s'te plaît
la merguez et dans le pain pita
uniquement si vous mettez beaucoup de
choses louches
c'est un petit peu ambigu comme phrase
c'est pas moi qui fait l'école ça vient
d'en haut
[Musique]
vous pouvez aller manger dans la salle
de réunion justicier là
[Musique]
bonjour cyril votre mission si toutefois
vous l'acceptez est de faire que la
première de touche pas à mon poste reste
dans les annales de la télévision
française
pour cela je vous ai monté une équipe
pas piquée des hannetons
benjamin castaldi à deux spécialités le
divorce et le camouflage avec ses
déguisements de dernière technologie
valérie benaïm la reine des boulettes du
brushing et des boulettes
vous avez dit deux fois boulette oui oui
il y en a deux sortes
jean michel maire en quarante ans de
carrière cet homme est passé expert dans
la transformation vocal delphine
wespiser miss france 2012
elle al'avantage de très bien connaître
les personnes âgées daniel moreau qui
revient dans l'équipe non pas pour
parler de télé mais pour trouver un mec
qui va la chope et isabelle morini bosc
cette journaliste dispose des meilleures
informations sur tous ses amis d'enfance
napoléon du capet ou encore
vercingétorix matthieu delormeau une
formidable recrues même si depuis une
mission avec des chiens sa carrière est
à l'arrêt géraldine maillet la seule
chroniqueuse capable de lire un livre de
1000 pages sans aucune image à
l'intérieur théo le tarbes à personne ne
le connaît mais on sait juste que c'est
un tarbais et bien sûr plein d'autres
chroniqueurs qui disparaîtront aussi
vite que rachid arhab
je vous envoie ses chroniqueurs
immédiatement ce message s'autodétruira
dans les cinq secondes à sa soul depuis
un peu plus de temps parce que c'était
bien là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]